this is helping you generate income this
is I mean 400 000 Subs you got to very
quickly 50 million pot you can do
sponsorships you can do a lot of
different things that's going on with
you got people that are watching so your
mind is not consumed with you know hey I
need money what do I need to do to go
make money so is this is this almost
eliminating the thoughts of
I got to figure out if I make money and
survive do you think that would have
prevented a lot of guys to get into life
with the technology we have today both
from the camera standpoint as well as
way to make money
I don't I don't know I really don't know
but you know my mindset was being a
gangster and I was a gangster the whole
time I don't think
I would have turned to this now I might
have had somebody else use P other
people and took a piece of some business
that they were doing in this field it
might interest me Hollywood might of
interest me in the background
I'm a camera guy I'm in the back I mean
I don't want to be in the front
now it's different
now I am I am in the front everything's
about my voice I can't even duck I can't
even go away for a weekend but I don't
know there's two sides of this sword
you can make money with it and people
should use it
and use it properly
and make money but the other side is
that I think the whole country now
is in a weird place
there's people who are doing some of
these platforms who are talking about
being in the mafia they're full of [ __ ]
they're not even they want nothing
nothing
and everybody seems a lot of them seem
to be lying so you got to disciple which
one is good which one is bad which one
is so there's a confusion about all of
this so it has two edges to this sword
I don't know and there's a lot of things
that are going on with kids today
that I I mean I don't understand
the whole country is just out of whack
if you would have told me about this
country at this point if four years ago
three years ago I would tell you crazy
that would never happen in the United
States in what way which part every pot
the coronavirus the whole thing
I mean the masks no masks I don't even
know what to believe anymore you used to
be you listen to the news
it was gospel oh my God this is what
they're saying on the news Cronkite
Cronkite all you know when you went back
the CNN the guy who originally formed
Santa to turn up people like that now
they disappeared I don't know what's
running it anymore you don't you can't
believe anything anymore because one day
they're telling you one thing
wear masks don't wear masks wear two
masks take a shot take another shot take
a booster take another booster
come on bro what what's going on here
two completely different realities yeah
yeah yeah and it's do you hear it in all
kinds of [ __ ] you don't know what to
believe this guy fouchy
I mean I don't know if he needs a medal
the sexiest man alive guys yeah yeah
sexy is it man alive well he bullshitted
the whole world
he's part of this whole virus like you
don't know if he's a hero he's a [ __ ]
he's no [ __ ] here with this guy he's
no hero he's paid for my I understand
the highest paid
guy in the federal government
is supposed to be a doctor he's supposed
to care about us
he's funding this thing in China
with money like we're paying for that
we're paying for
to get a bat who is disgusting and
has all kinds of viruses and we're
getting those viruses and trying to
transform them into worse viruses the
worst virus and making it that man could
catch it for what reason are we doing it
the excuse is so if man catches this
we could uh cure it that's [ __ ]
because
from the bat you can't even get it first
of all bats don't even live near us and
you can't get it so you're creating
something to see what you can cure
bro millions of people have died from
this
and the word hero Broadus is the
furthest thing from a hero
well we can't explain what I would like
to do to him
[Music]
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]